hier ist es einfach so eisig wir sind
gerade stecken geblieben ehrlich wir
wollten schon fast den adac rufen so und
vor oder sieht bisschen größer aus
schon wieder der nächste unfall
[Musik]
so etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen
bei diesem neuen video leute heute wird
es wenn ich krank es wird richtig geil
ich hoffe es klappt auch alles so wie
ich mir das vorgestellt habe
ich habe schon ein bisschen hier in
unserem wohnzimmer ausgeräumt also alles
schön sauber und auch ein bisschen platz
gemacht und zwar genau
ja also da sollte auf jeden fall
eigentlich perfekt reichen ich habe ja
lasst uns das video hochgeladen wo ihr
abstimmen könnt was ich denn für ein
automatik kaufe und gleich automat 1 hat
mit ziemlich vielen likes auf jeden fall
gewonnen
wenn ich euch mal koalitionen ein leute
ganz kurz an die die gar keinen plan
haben wovon nicht gerade überhaupt rede
weil das muss ich jetzt noch kurz mit
drei nimmt übrigens nämlich das jetzt
machen auch ich war gestern beim friseur
sind meine haare endlich wieder kurz
könnte ja mal die kommentare schreiben
wie es aussieht ich habe auf jeden fall
letztes mal ein video hochgeladen
da habe ich euch verschiedene automaten
gezeigt und euch eine auswahl gegeben
was ich dann halt am ende dann kaufen
soll hier konnte das alles hier mit dem
daumen nach oben abstimmen haben einen
spielautomaten bei 800 likes
kaffeeautomat bei 268 likes greif
automat 1 2798 likes red bull automat
1800 weit über 2 800 gehen was also
greift automatisch hat wirklich mit
abstand gewonnen hat mich auch sehr
gefreut ich meinen hätte ich selber auch
am liebsten gekauft auto mal eins war
dieser hier jetzt habe ich nämlich eben
was durcheinander gebracht diesen konnte
ich nicht kaufen weil der nicht durch
unsere tür gepasst hätte von der masse
herab und hier mit dem bin ich mir nicht
einig geworden ich meinen 900 euro ich
habe jetzt halt später was sich bezahlt
habe dann hatten wir hier noch so halten
aber ist an sich auch egal also das ging
auf jeden fall greift automaten der hier
wurzeln nicht aber meiner meinung nach
eigentlich dann noch cholera wobei der
auch nicht schlecht aussieht war leider
zu groß also lass dich überraschen
ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß
damit und ja
ja wenn ich nicht sagen und ja das ding
ist der typ von greif automat 1 zweigen
ein bisschen kompliziert und ja ich weiß
nicht ich würde jetzt auch gar nicht zu
sehr ins detail gehen auf jeden fall
musste ich dann weiterschauen habe aber
ganz schön und anderen automaten
gefunden der eigentlich fast genauso
aussieht und mit dem bin ich mich einig
geworden genau heute schneit es
natürlich in köln
und wir haben es gleich ungefähr eine
stunde fahrt für uns also schon ganz
schön lang aber so ist das was tut man
nicht alles für seinen eigenen reim
automaten ich habe wirklich bock und ich
freue mich wenn das ding gesteht alter
wer hat einfach zu hause in den eigenen
automaten das ist ja mal sowas von
einzigartig genau das war dagegen nicht
aus ich wollte auf jeden fall nochmal
der bahn habe ein bisschen bargeld
abgehoben weil wir haben uns darauf
geeinigt das ganze in bar auszumachen
ich glaube der welt ursprünglich 600
euro haben dafür marco koch war das auch
irgendwas machen kann hab s einfach mal
auch wenn ich das natürlich nicht alles
mit filmen kann so ich meine der wird
dann wahrscheinlich denken wollen machte
er dann mit der kamera ist ja irgendwie
immer so
so leute wir sind jetzt hier noch auf
seinem hänger hoch weil wir brauchen ja
ein transportmittel dass wir den automat
überhaupt transportieren können und hier
stehen auf jeden fall der menge aber
anhänger vermietung so also das gleiche
leute ist es wild am schneiden wir haben
hier
wir schleichen praktisch auf die
autobahn deswegen verzögert sich unsere
ankunft ein bisschen aber was macht man
nicht alles für einen carve out oder
nein wir haben jetzt deutschland unfall
gesehen weil es hier halt so schneiden
und wir sind unterwegs über diesen
dicken anhänger der anderen den scheiß
automaten abzuholen
also dann wenn uns jetzt etwas passieren
sollte das kann man ja keinem erzählen
als folge rutschte und die polizei hatte
hätten schon die strecke abgesperrt weil
da halt der unfall passiert ist und da
irgendjemand direkt im graben will
flogen ist aber hauptsache dann
passieren wenn uns was passiert dann
bevor wir den automaten abgeholt haben
weil sonst da nämlich auch schritt ist
es einfach so eisig wir sind gerade
stecken blieben ehrlich wir wollten
schon fast den adac routen und jetzt
fahren wir hier auf kainz weiter hoch es
ist einfach alles vereist das ist aber
so dumm
also was ein dummer chip naja ich glaube
ich wieder rein er ich habe wirklich
gedacht das war es jetzt versucht da
kommen wir nicht mal weg so und vor oder
sieht bisschen größer aus dann schon
wieder der nächste unfall oder bremst
sondern feuerwehrautos ne
als ich glaube einen dümmeren tag hätte
man sich dafür auf jeden fall nicht
aussuchen können
so leute nach zweieinhalb stunden also
ich habe gedacht wir sind jetzt schon
längst wieder in köln zurück der
autobahn ist eingeladen ist wirklich ein
richtig gutes gerät glaube ich also ich
kann mich damit ja auch nicht wirklich
aus aber auf jeden fall in einem top
zustand war auch eine super super nette
familie über das abgeholt haben also
schöne grüße auch an die töchter und wir
fahren jetzt durch das schneegestöber
und zurück nach köln
und dann kriegt er einen platz in
unserer wohnung natürlich muss man auch
erst mal hinkriegen deswegen will ich
sagen da sehen wir uns dann bis gleich
und dann zeige ich euch dann auch mal
zum ersten mal
ja ich freue mich auf jeden fall auf die
videos die damit kommen werden das habe
ich jetzt schon mal sagen
bis gleich
und sonst so
die beiden
dieses video 14001 nicht einmal sehr
rasch auf unsere türen
dadurch entstehen denn nur wenn die tür
so aufgeht das alter er glaubt nicht was
du die anstrengung diese scheiße was
willst denn durch den kompletten
schneestürmen gefahren war dann irgendwo
in so einem dorf wo es erst mal 500
meter den berg gefühlt hochging da sind
wir fast im graben stecken geblieben und
jetzt wird das ding gar sechs stücke
dass das so derart ausfindig oder
behindert also die habe ich ja letzte
mal da rausgeholt doppeln
ich kann ja nicht
doch einfach so wer jetzt als erstes ein
haus holt darf inhalten politisch passt
auch jetzt starb dann aber ich liebe es
jetzt schon
[Musik]
denkst du stellst du ja export
das gute daran muss kein geld leihen
dürfen jetzt so bei mir ist es haben die
vorbesitzer schon eingerichtet und will
jetzt hier fahren
[Musik]
naja besser da ist einfach schon einer
jetzt kannst du die union aus
da muss noch ein bisschen üben ja das
ist es hat auch ein bisschen was zu tun
dass man erst mal ein bisschen das
gefühl bekommen hey leute ich freue mich
wirklich so ne ich hätte gedacht das
wird niemals was dass der irgendwann mal
steht oder irgendwo stehen sondern muss
sagen das ist wirklich ein guter automat
also ich habe da vielleicht 600 euro
bezahlt ich denke mal dass es ein fairer
preis für so etwas angeboten vielmehr
haben für den größten schrott leute also
bevor wir das irgendwie rein gehen bald
folgen wirklich geile videos und die
videos ich freue mich so darauf dass wir
richtig geil ich weiß ich also die
meisten euch soll der sohn automaten
kennen ihr habt nun wahrscheinlich noch
nie von innen gesehen also wie sieht das
dritte aus ich kann so immer kurz zeigen
wir haben praktisch den ganzen computer
also hier kann man auf jeden fall alles
mögliche um stellen hier zum beispiel
die musik lauter machen
[Musik]
es hört sich gar nicht gesund sein also
am besten machen wir die ganz ganz ganz
ganz leise auf jeden fall alles wirklich
interessant finde ich wir haben dann
einfach mal selber so ein paar
stofftiere die wir halt in seiner
wohnung hat freitag und so ein bisschen
gespielt das war ja nix ne story zeigt
das war es eigentlich bis hierhin mit
dem video wenn dies feiert das sehr
gerne den daumen nach oben da ich kann
euch mal kurz ein bisschen ja anti sahen
was damit oder was für videos damit
folgen werden und zwar habe ich vor auf
jeden fall mehrere parks zu machen ich
werde immer ein paar freunde von mir
einladen natürlich irgendwann krassen
gegenstand wenn zum beispiel ein iphone
oder so und dann wird immer abwechselnd
hintereinander gespielt und der das
handy dann bekommt mit dem greifarm darf
es behalten das ganze kann man ja mit
ganz ganz viele verschiedene sachen
machen und ich glaube dass wir da
wirklich harte challes so vor allem wenn
also fünf leute auf dieses iphone auf
bayern kann man ja sozusagen also ich
freue mich wirklich sehr darauf und das
was von diesem tag heute war wirklich
anstrengend das ding überhaupt
hinzukriegen empfehle ich euch nicht 120
kilo weiß ja gut das war es von mir vor
was hat euch gefallen und hat rein